marcus strowman got rained out of his
start last night good to go today
rymiltopia steps in against marcus
strowman
swinging a bouncing ball to first got
the sinker that time slider actually
picked by mccann steps on the bag in
time one man away brian mcmahon coming
up one-two pitch is hit to the left side
and through for a base hit rockies get a
one-out single
on the left side he goes the pitch swung
out and missed throw to second and the
ball got away
and ryan is in there safely with a
stolen base his third of the year
as story goes down on strikes
numbers be his 11th start as well the
one complete game was against the mets
vr swings and hits it to first they go
to second for one story back to first
double play
boy what a quick turn fuentes to story
and back to first great play and gets
himself back to the bag get a look at
him coming off right here
you see the footwork
i love the backhand play trevor with the
spin throw
and an absolute strike first
airman trying to finish off this first
inning pitch swang and a miss got him
with a slider we've played an inning no
score in new york the rockies get a
one-out base runner and garrett hampson
will be the better
toward the middle lindor with a great
diving stop and they get the out at
second oh wow
first the full extension dive and then
the glow flip on a hop to peraza and
they get the force play on rogers that
was spectacular
i mean see how far he goes to get that
and then flip it out of his glove for
peraza to be able to keep that left foot
on the bag
that was
fine indeed
tomas nedo two strikes swung on and
missed second punch out for herman
one two this time he misses the breaking
ball swing and a miss and airmon has
three strikeouts no score after two
perazo leads off against jeremiah
marquez
and gets a first pitch breaking ball
flies it deep to left back goes tapia at
the
head
jose perazo with his second home run as
a met
and the mets get the early lead it's one
nothing in the third see the side swing
of frost it gets it way out in front and
that's why it was pulled and hit it
right on the screws cameron maven
and maven down on three pitches that's
the fourth strikeout for marquez is in
vr draws the walk with two out and it'll
get lindor to the plate 2016. there's a
bunt from the door to mcmahon
bare hand did he get him
got him unbelievable play by mcmahon
tremendous defensive play
mcmahon with the bare hand play throws
out lindor trevor story leads off the
fourth against marcus stroman story hits
one end of the shift right at lindor
one pitch and one out for stroman it's
five ground ball outs for marcus among
his first 10 outs two out to the runner
on second
rolled over down to third vr handles it
and the throw is true to retire the side
halfway through halfway through second
and back for a bikini king former first
rounder for oakland shoots it into left
center
tapia will run it down menino's getting
a chance to play with all the injuries
mccann is
really the starter behind the play
benito is getting an opportunity this
base hit up the middle
it's amazing what happens when he gets
steady at bats those bats turn out to be
quality brandon drury comes up over one
with the strikeout
sky left side
man's got it fighting the sun maybe a
little wind
garrett hampson
hit a ground ball that looked like a
base hit his first time up and then a
glove flip to get a forest hampstead
lays down a bunch strumming off the
mount like a cap and he throws him out
strowman not only pitching well but
having a gold glove kind of an afternoon
he was on that ball almost before
hampson laid it down and he got over
there and backhanded it i stopped
backhanded but bare-handed it and made
the accurate throw so dom nunez will be
the better
and he grounds this one to the right
side into the shift and there's lindor
to throw him out
so two more ground ball outs to start
this fifth inning for strowman who's
really settled into a nice groove
oh one pitch swinging in a line drive
into left field for a base hit well
airmon marquez
gets a two two-out single
for airmon his third hit of the year
that ball stayed on the plate
looked like he
was trying to get that slider past
airmon and just didn't get it to break
down and away
he has been sharp
just the one mistake peraza swings at a
fastball and hits this to center field
into right center now hampson makes the
catch disgrounded mcmahon mcmahon will
retire
maybe at first make that over 23. marcus
strowman working on the shutout through
five innings here's the 2-2 to mcmahon
swung on and missed strike three he bury
that slider at his ankle
and for marcus strowman his third
strikeout the big one to start the sixth
just the third strike up but 10 of the
16 outs have come on
the ground so back to form for strowman
now here's charlie blackman
and blackman hits it out to center this
one hangs up for maven two out
one and two to fuente story runs the
pitch looped in the air shallow right
the kenny towards the line still coming
makes the catch in fair territory and
that retires the side no runs a hit
no errors
one man left middle of the sixth inning
in a seven inning game the one to
nothing score at the moment
two twos this time swung out and missed
with the slider no check swing there
this is shot right back towards vermont
it hits him on the side
flips it to first get lindor out again
see it right back at him 104 off the bat
only good thing i would say is that it
catches him in a meaty spot sin edwin
diaz in to try and close it out well
that's the right moves brandon rodgers
leads off in the seven two to rogers
tapped past the mound right there is
perazo
one out barrett hampson will be the bad
aaron and hampson grounds one down to
third two hopper for vr
two out the rockies are down to their
final strike he struck him out and the
ball game is over
a one two three seventh
for edwin diaz saving it for marcus
strowman
jose perazza holmes for the only run the
mets play some spectacular defense and
they take the opener of the doubleheader
from the rockies one to nothing